reconnaissez-vous cette pâtisserie
si vous pouviez en percevoir le parfum
je suis sûr que vous auriez trouvé c'est
un pain d épice aller aujourd'hui dans
sur la planche on va voir ce qu'il a
dans le ventre pâques des épices
[Musique]
mais d'abord un peu d'histoire et de
géographie j'aime bien raconter d'où
viennent les aliments que nous
consommons souvent je me régale et vous
aussi j'espère le pain d épice viendrait
de chine après s'être répandu jusqu'au
moyen-orient dans le sillage des armées
de l'empereur gengis khan les croisés
aurait ensuite rapporté la recette en
europe aux 12e et au xiiie siècle
souvent confectionnés par les moines
durant la période de noël certaines
villes françaises en ont fait une de
leurs spécialités
reims dijon guebwiller en alsace où il
ya même un musée du pain d'épicés chacun
a d'ailleurs sa recette à paris il y
avait même une foire au pain d'épicés
qui se déroulait chaque année à pâques
c'est l'ancêtre de la foire du trône bon
je voudrais pas gâcher la fête mais on
est dans sur la planche est la recette
tu as raison dans un pain et pis il y à
des épices bien sûr mais pas que
direction la cuisine je les dis chacun à
sa manière de confectionner le pain et
pis aussi je vais faire au plus simple
et tâcher de contenter tout moment il
faut de la farine de blé rens on utilise
aussi de la farine de seigle de la
levure chimique de l'eau du sucre un
zeste de citron un peu de beurre mais ce
n'était pas obligatoire en alsace on
utilise aussi des oeufs et puis bien sûr
il faut des épices traditionnellement
quatre épices que les palais les plus
fins peuvent deviner que la cannelle de
la badiane ou anis étoilé du gingembre
et des clous de girofle mais c'est pas
ça le clou du spectacle
évidemment non on dit pas mais pis mais
l'ingrédient qui fait tout c'est le elle
j'adore le miel c'est plein de bonnes
choses et puis ça se conserve très
longtemps vous rendez compte celui ci a
été récolté il y a plus d'allant comme
le secret du pain d'épicés de laisser
reposer la pâte pendant très longtemps
on va en profiter pour regarder ce qu'il
y a dans ce miel
le miel vous le savez est produit par
des abeilles bon tout ça elle qui aimait
tant pour moi alors je ne reviens pas
sur la manière dont elle procède au beau
si quand même une petite piqûre de
rappel bon d'accord mais dare dare et
c'est bien parce que c'est toi les
abeilles produisent du miel à partir du
nectar qu'elle récolte sur les fleurs
ces dernières secrète ce liquide dont
les abeilles se nourrissent et à partir
duquel elles font des réserves les
abeilles aspire le nectar le stock dans
leur jabot puis retourne pas la ruche où
d'autres abeilles le récupère
l'ingurgiter leur tour avant de les
déverser dans des alvéoles de fil en
aiguille le nectar se transforme en miel
qui à l'origine est là pour nourrir la
colonie pendant l'hiver bon je vous
rassure les apiculteurs qui prennent
grand soin de leurs ruches en laisse
suffisamment pour que les abeilles ne
meurent pas de faim pendant la saison
froide
l'être humain consomment du miel depuis
au moins 9000 à l'origine c'était à la
fois une gourmandise est un remède sur
le papyrus d'edwin smith c'est le nom
d'un régime lol qui l'a eu en sa
possession durant quelques temps sur ce
papyrus lieu de 3500 ans est considéré
comme l'un des plus anciens textes de
médecine il est précisé que le miel est
utilisé pour soigner les blessures ça
peut surprendre mais ça n'a rien
d'étonnant le miel est acide il est
pauvre en eau il contient du peroxyde
d'hydrogène un antiseptique tout à fait
naturel il a donc des vertus
cicatrisantes et antimicrobiennes
certains hôpitaux l'utilisent
aujourd'hui pour soigner des plaies ou
des brûlures et ce sont d'ailleurs ces
propriétés qui permettent au miel de se
conserver longtemps très longtemps ou
vous ne verrez jamais une couche de
moisissures se développer à la surface
du miel privés d'eau et dans un milieu
acide les bactéries et les champignons
beaucoup de mal à se développer
tiens tu devrais prendre un peu de miel
il soulage certaine tout d'abord parce
qu'il tapissé protège les muqueuses de
la gorge et ensuite parce qu'on m'a dit
il a des propriétés antiseptiques par
contre si vous en prenez le soir c'est
avant de vous brosser les dents le miel
contient des glucides du sucre si vous
préférez qui favorise le développement
des caries aux bahamas on pourrait
presque vivent
au départ l'homme récolter le miel dans
les ruches d'abeilles sauvages et
certains peuples procède toujours de
cette manière
c'est le cas de la tribu yao au
mozambique qui a une manière très
particulière de procéder pour dénicher
les ruches ses membres utilisent les
services de cet oiseau au nom très
évocateur il s'agit d'un grand
indicateur depuis les airs l'oiseau
repère facilement les ruches dans les
arbres et se pose à proximité les
humains n'ont plus qu'à grimper il
chasse les abeilles récupère le miel et
les oiseaux la cire le problème c'est
qu'en procédant de cette manière la
colonie est à chaque fois disperser et
la ruche détruite c'est pour cette
raison que l'homme élèves des abeilles
domestiques dans des ruches d'où on peut
extraire le miel sans dommage
heureusement j'ai du stock il a quand
même drôle de tête celui là tu as vu la
tienne mais non je parle de la couleur
t'inquiète la couleur du miel n'a
strictement rien à voir avec son
évolution dans le temps elle est liée
aux pigments qui se trouve dans le
nectar des fleurs que les abeilles
butinent ce ne sont pas les mêmes d'une
essence à l'autre le miel de lavande par
exemple est plutôt clair les deux
presque blanc celui d'acacia et jaune
pâle celui de sapins tirs sur l'orangé
alors que celui de châtaignier écart est
membre à l'origine du nectar joue aussi
sur la consistance du miel suivant les
essences les nectars n'ont pas la même
composition en sucre or c'est l'
équilibre en glucose et fructose les
deux sucres l'intérieur qui déterminent
la vitesse à laquelle le mienne va
cristalliser un miel contenant beaucoup
de fructose comme celui d'acacia reste
liquide pendant longtemps al'inverse
amiel riche en cause comme le miel de
colza
cristallise très rapidement celui ci a
été récolté il y a quelques mois
seulement et on voit déjà les petits
cristaux de sucre attention ça n'a rien
à voir avec la qualité du miel tous ces
miels n'ont pas non plus les mêmes vous
puisqu'ils sont réalisés à partir de
différents hectares personnellement
c'est le miel de châtaignier que je
préfère et vous quel est votre miel
favori dites le moi en commentaire
là bas qu'est ce que tu fais je me suis
coupé et alors et j'ai lu dans
l'encyclopédie guinot que le pain d
épice pouvait être utilisé comme
cataplasme en chirurgie je me demande
s'il ne devrait pas consultés allez un
bon conseil le pain d épice manger le
c'est délicieux et c'est bon pour le
moral à bientôt les épis curieuse et des
épis curieux et pour continuer de vous
régaler
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche
vient du peroxyde d'hydrogène
d'hydrogène se va pas
[Applaudissements]